hey guys i am just mcdonald it's the
fourth of april and i don't have a poem
for you today but i do have a bunch of
really cool news story so let's get into
those instead i think it's for the best
first up some rumors dragon age
inquisition details as obtained through
a leak sorry Bioware said leak has come
from the latest issue of official Xbox
Magazine which somebody managed to get
their hands on early apparently the game
will have 40 possible endings with five
major regions to explore including for
Eldon the free marches or late navara
and the Dales there are also hints that
the game's dialogue system will feature
three separate dialogue wheels the tone
will the choice wheel and the reaction
wheel I don't know about you guys that
makes me really excited new Xbox boss
Phil Spencer said that there will be a
huge army of franchises to look forward
to at e3 this year Spencer said there
are loads of people investing in you and
great triple-a IP and that between
themselves EA Activision Sony and
Nintendo we're in for a significant wave
of cool franchises in news of new ways
to waste time without working towards
any tangible goal catching pokemon on
google maps with the thing this week in
what was essentially an elaborate April
Fool's jerk people could catch pokemon
dwelling around local streets and
international locations in the hopes of
collecting them all although it seems
that nobody was able to find new the
game was a massive hit for like at least
a day and a half as the things that are
completely uncool apparently oculus
employees were getting death threats
after the Facebook buyout people may not
have been over the moon about the
acquisition but some seem to have taken
it to the next level by making harassing
phone calls and sending death threats to
oculus employees and their
please there has been overwhelming
negativity over the buyout from facebook
but whether you're for it or against it
I think we can all agree that this is
going way way too far in last depressing
news the witcher 3 already seemed like
it was going to look totally awesome but
now CD Projekt RED have confirmed that
it will indeed look totally awesome the
death have says it on pc ps4 and xbox
one they've been able to go nuts with
visuals without having to choose between
optimizing graphics or performance we
already heard that the game was close to
maxing out the power of the new
generation console so it's great to hear
that no corners are being cut for the
hugely anticipated RPG let me know if
you got tricked by any April Fool's
jokes this week and what news you can
about either in that comment section
down below or you can do so on my
twitter where i'm at jess mcdonald this
week on site zarine and i take on co-op
survival horror in house of horrors chem
digs into morality in gaming on reality
check and rampant piracy is invading GTA
5 in GTA diaries that is it for all the
gaming things that i have to tell you
about this week but as always thank you
very much for your time and attention
and I hope you have a great weekend